entwickelt vom neuen film nach berlin
zur filmpremiere und sam premiere
eingeladen wo ich einer den viele von
euch treffen konnte mit euch auf einer
coolen party sein durfte und vor allem
auch im film sehen durfte das ganze
wochenende in berlin habe ich mal wird
geblockt und ich jetzt einfach mal
[Musik]
[Applaus]
richtig bock verspricht in wessen ich
sage einfach zu wenig
einer stunde
[Musik]
ja
viele fotos wir waren jetzt die gerade
auf der power systems mit auf dem roten
teppich an den film steht noch immer an
komm schon auf
power rangers im kino erstmal die
special effekte waren absolute hammer
history war auch echt stark der anfang
dieser einleitung einfach
erwähnen
[Musik]
ich bin jetzt wieder hier in meiner
wohnung in köln angekommen und werde
euch das ganze wochenende kurz
zusammenfassen ich muss wirklich sagen
dass mir eine kooperation mit einem
unternehmen mit seiner marke mit dem
kinofilm power rangers noch nie so viel
spaß macht hat die dieses wochenende
einfach erstens so unfassbar dieses
video für euch zu drehen was ich vor
einiger zeit hoch geladen habe
und jetzt dürfte die premiere hier
besuchen ich konnte so viele von euch
zuschauer interessen wir konnten uns so
viele sachen unterhalten werden enorm
vielseitig konnte fotos machen ich habe
auch viele von euch dann nach einem kino
getroffen und doch bei der aftershow und
ich muss wirklich sagen der film hat mir
in meinen freunden mega gut gefallen hat
wie der blog schon gesagt ist es die
perfekte kombination ableiten wissen die
irgendwie geritten werden zwischendurch
zu enormen trockenen humor den ich
einfach mega feiert er auch hier an
meinem blog spiel so ein bisschen
gemerkt also immer diese kurzen wird
zwischendurch in die fürbitten
abgefuckte also dass er auch meine art
von humor die darum was in dem film
verbunden mit enormer action wie zum
beispiel im endkampf ich will ganz profi
verraten also schaut euch auf jeden fall
mein kino an der es ab 12 freigegeben
und kommt ab jetzt 23 überall in den
deutschen kinos verfügbare geht auf
jeden fall mal rein damit ihr euch noch
ein bisschen was darunter vorstellen
können wenn nicht jeder mann wird über
vom trailer ein
das ist eine menge geld
[Musik]
sonst will ich an dieser stelle sagen
dankeschön kapazitive enorm keine
kooperation dass ich das alles nicht
möglich gemacht hat dass ich viele von
euch treffen konnte uns weiter und so
fort
für den fünfmal am anfang konnten und
die haben ja party am ende ich weiß aber
wie ihr gesehen habt nicht bewegen in
berlin werden wird sich einige neue
sachen geplant die beispielsweise buch
ich will gar nichts zu sagen auf jeden
fall sind viele geile sachen in der
pipeline ich bin jetzt wieder in köln
ich bin froh dass der biedere mit in
ruhe habe ihr tage wie ich nach spanien
paletten albers dabei mega viel spaß
gemacht und ich hoffe wenn ihr dort
verordnet hat bei euch aufgefallen
ja das kann leicht da mein magen knurrt